why do I make promises that I can't keep
this question came up during my Q&A
panel when I was at VidCon over the last
weekend and oddly enough it didn't come
from the audience I ran this Q&A a
little bit differently because I wanted
to answer questions that I asked myself
questions like Who am I Who am I to you
guys like why do I make videos how did I
get to this point right here and more
pertinent questions like why do I make
promises that I can't keep because if
you've been watching my videos for
awhile you know what I'm talking about
it's not a thing out of maliciousness or
it's not me outright lying to you guys I
have ambitions and I want to reach high
I want to accomplish them so I often
find myself making promises that I don't
keep up with and the panel itself was
really really interesting for me and I
hope it was interesting for the people
out in the audience but more than that
it was a moment of self-reflection for
me like it was a moment where I could
just have an honest true discussion with
you guys about Who I am and who I was
and who I will be and where I'm going
with this and that question just kind of
stuck with me because I've a Glee
answered it onstage but then I kept
thinking about it why why do I make
promises that I can't keep why am I not
keeping them and if I can't keep them
why do I make them in the first place am
I not working hard enough to make sure
that happens am i lazy am i forgetful
and so I'll get to the finer details of
this answer later on in the video but to
understand my mindset right now I have
to talk about something that happened
just last night if you weren't there we
were running a charity livestream over
on Twitch we weren't doing it over here
on YouTube so don't be surprised if you
didn't see it but we were over there on
Twitch and it was really really awesome
because Bob flew into town and we were
having so much fun and we had all these
challenge videos that we were doing I
have a t-shirt challenge that I'm
probably going to post a video later but
then later on
had this guy by the name of Alaskan Blue
Jay on YouTube who I met through two
make-a-wish Foundation while I was at
VidCon and I promised him that I would
bring him on board for the livestream
and I almost forgot
but thankfully I've got friends that
reminded me to call him in and we called
him and we had a nice discussion and he
told this story this really really
impactful story that resonated
throughout the rest of the stream then
I'll try to do it justice right now he
probably heard it he didn't make it up
or north neither did I but it's the
story of this young child walks along
the beach and on this Beach
hundreds of starfish wash on shore
doomed to dry out and die but this child
walks along and every time he sees one
he picks one up and he throws it back
into view giving it another chance of
life he can't get to all of them but
every morning this child on his way to
wherever he's going
picks up another starfish and tosses it
back in the game and he does this every
day for a while day by day walking along
the beach tossing another starfish back
in and one day this old man has been
seeing him do this comes up to the child
and asks why are you doing this hundreds
and hundreds of starfish wash up on the
shore every day and you can never save
all of them why even bother you're not
making a difference and the child looked
at the man and looked down the ground at
a starfish at his feet he picked up that
starfish and tossed it back in the ocean
and said it mattered to that one and
that's the story and it's a simple story
with a simple message meaning that if
you do something even in the grand
scheme of the huge insurmountable
obstacle that is the bigger problem if
you chip in just a little bit it will go
so far but then almost immediately after
he told that story we were just talking
there he started screaming J Alaskan
Blue Jay started screaming through the
phone and we didn't know what to make of
it I thought maybe the TV will
it was like a joke or a prank I had no
idea but what happened was his
defibrillator in his chest went off
right on a stream and it scared the crap
huh it scared the crap out of everybody
everyone in stream was so scared and I
didn't really know what to do I tried to
stay calm about the situation he went to
the hospital immediately I tried to stay
in contact with him as of right now I
believe he has had home resting It was
as he was told it was probably a
malfunction more than something
life-threatening but they are monitoring
him and he is doing okay and as an aside
if you could send some love to him he
has a YouTube channel Alaskan Blue Jay
I'll put a link in the description but
the point here is after that story was
told and after he went to the hospital
after that big scare
Catherine helped start this campaign of
$1 donations we had $100,000 goal for
this charity livestream to go to
AbleGamers and we were behind if we were
actually behind and then Catherine kind
of like started this march of dollars
where if someone donated we could see
who donated and if they left a comment
she asked that they comment starfish and
for those of you don't know Catherine is
my editor and good friend and they
commented starfish and after that not
only did the chat take it upon
themselves to start the hashtag pray for
Jay but also do really really rallied
around this concept that these $1
donations could make all the difference
in the world and then we solved like the
counter steadily rocket up names were
flying by everyone who's saying starfish
people were donating for other people in
saying here's 20 starfish here's a
hundred starfish someone donated a
thousand dollars and was like here
here's starfish for everybody that
couldn't be there and can donate and it
was this beautiful beautiful thing this
avalanche of $1 donation the the
representation of what that meant in the
face of being scared for Jay
and after there I kept up with them he
gave us an update when he went to the
hospital he tried to stay on the screen
he tried to like actually watch the
screen while he was in the hospital
which I applaud that so much and and it
was this beautiful beautiful thing that
came out of mages meeting this one guy
and him telling a simple story and
everyone chipping in $1 donations and
without that I don't even know if we
would have made our goal and this all
tied in to the question why do I make
promises that I can't keep because I
made a promise to Jay that I would bring
him on the stream and I almost forgot
not out of maliciousness but just
because I got caught up with other
things and I got busy and I allowed
myself to become complacent and I don't
mean to turn his tragedy into something
that it's not
but without that I don't think we would
have had the drive to keep going I don't
think it would have resonated as hard as
it did and so when I asked myself why do
I make promises that I can't keep and I
think about the answer that I gave on
stage all of that is [ __ ] if I make
a promise and I don't keep it
I am [ __ ] because if I didn't keep
my promise what would we have missed out
on I wouldn't have been able to talk to
Jay and get to know him and you guys
wouldn't know his story and we may not
have made our goal and how many times in
the past have I made promises that I
didn't keep and what opportunities did I
miss because of that I don't want to do
that ever again
I'm almost 28 I'm going to be 28 in two
days here and I do not want to live my
life making promises that are empty in
all the ambition and all the the swept
up nature of the tour and going doing
these ambitious projects and going to
VidCon and going to conventions meeting
people and doing other quote-unquote
bigger projects I
I feel like I've lost sight of the small
things made it important for what I do
here and I made excuses for it and I've
relied on the fact that I am so happy
that my friends are here to support me
and and my friends are here with me who
have been with me for years and Bob who
flew into town for me just for this
dream because it's a cause that he
believed in and he wanted to join me in
this fun day that we had and it was the
most fun stream that we've had for a
long time and it was all because and it
was it was all because we were able to
band together and we were able to keep
this one promise and we're able to keep
doing these things over and over again
and we're able to keep doing them in the
future because that's what's important
this community is what's important in
jus your what's important about this
channel that is the only thing that
keeps me going and it's so easy for me
to forget it
even if I'm focused on the why and I
know in my heart that I'm doing this for
you and I'm doing this because I'd love
to do it even that isn't enough because
if I let things slip through the cracks
and I know I'm not perfect but if I let
something as important as a promise go
by I mean while I'm Ina with that grand
statement and a bunch of wording is what
I'm here to say is that I'm here for you
because I owe everything that I have to
you and if I'm going to be in this
position where I'm able to talk to
millions of people up and try to steer
this community in a direction that I
think is genuinely good and I have to
hold myself to a higher standard
not just in being better as an
entertainer but being better as a
reliable friend and so I will make one
promise starting off this new age of
marklar where my
word is my bond the schedule starting
tomorrow we'll be back and we'll never
falter 8 and 12 Pacific Standard Time
you'll give videos and I will tie in the
ambition that I have I will tie in the
lofty goals that I have and I will keep
these promises and whenever I promise
you don't sleep even if it's here
through a video or if it's when I'm
meeting you in person if I promise it
it's going to happen I guarantee that
because if I don't keep those promises
I'm not worthy of you guys even giving
me a moment of your time so I know this
got serious I know it did and and I feel
like a hat after the emotions of the
tour and then the the windstorm of
VidCon and coming back for the charity
livestream and just this blur of the
past few weeks and then approaching my
birthday which I think you guys know
that I don't really care about my
birthday I I just want to say this is
the best thing that's ever happened to
me what you guys have given me is the
best thing that's ever happened to me
and I should treat it as such so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
thank you to chika
because Keiko was the hero of the
library because like all that aside the
one individual that made the most
donations was chika because we did a pet
upon and there is an infinite pet dead
she could you mind me putting you up
before with a little cheer a little bit
but chika was the true hero of this
livestream and I owe her a hundred
thousand and every one of you guys
because we do do two movies up there and
you look great Bubba you look like
select add
again hope you know the motive of you
and i'm meaning
100% meaning there is no lie here
there's no false promises here this is
everything so thank you everybody so
much for watching
Thank You chief for being there thank
you my friends who supported me thank
you Bob who flew into town thank you
Alaskan blue jay for staying so strong
and thank you everybody that I met over
this past weekend and as always we will
see you in the next video bye-bye boo
boo boo boo just happy puppy paws on a
puppy OH
[Music]
I mostly don't have don't have even on
telly I don't don't don't
oh no